est-ce que vous choisissez dans le
public tous les soirs une fille qu'on
vous ramène après dans votre chambre
pourquoi une seule
bonsoir Gabriel bonsoir bonsoir
Gabriel
français anglais je parle un peu mais
peut-être c'est plus facile
est-ce qu'il y a un traducteur oui oui
tu t'appelles comment Robert comme
toujours c'est Robert
comme toujours à mon avis c'est pas
possible
[Rires]
Gabriel a été le leader de Genesis
pendant la période la plus créative du
groupe ensuite vous avez entamé une
carrière solo commercialement réussi
mais toujours à l'avant-garde vous avez
été le premier à vous intéresser aux
musiques du monde le premier à vous
intéresser aux grandes causes
humanitaires bref vous avez toujours été
une espèce de préc curseur ouvert sur le
monde la classe
alors on va parler un petit peu de votre
vie Peter Gabriel vous êtes né dans le
Soray en 1950 vous avez les parents
idéaux pour devenir Peter Gabriel parce
que votre père est ingénieur électricien
il s'appelle Gabriel déjà
qui invente la première version de la
télé câblée finalement votre père non
il y a besoin
d'un système de télévision câblais qui
s'appelle
ça vous donne une idée pour vous donner
une idée de ce que c'était il fallait
avoir accès à cette télé par un système
de téléphone de cadran téléphonique
voilà en tous les cas voilà donc votre
père était un électronicien on voit bien
pourquoi après vous êtes branché là
dedans il faisait du yoga en plus
s'explique aussi beaucoup de choses et
votre mère était pianiste elle vous a
donné des leçons de piano mais vous avez
aussi fait donner des leçons de danse
d'équitation enfin vraiment une enfance
parfaite
de recevoir des leçons tout le temps un
peu un petit peu comme vous un moment
mais lui c'est à 9 ans et c'est il s'est
révolté contre tout ça et il a dit j'en
ai marre des leçons de piano dès le
centre de danse dès le son d'équitation
et tout ça mais ses parents lui ont dit
fais gaffe tu vas le regretter et en
fait c'est vrai vous l'avez regretté
après
exprimer ce que je voulais à travers mes
mes doigts ma main mais quand même
j'aurais préféré regarder peut-être un
peu plus la télé d'ailleurs voilà et
ensuite vous allez au collège et c'est
au collège que vous avez rencontré ce
avec qui vous formerait le fameux groupe
Genesis alors ce qu'on peut dire pour
les plus jeunes parce que Genesis c'est
vrai que ça doit être pas quand même
d'hier c'est que Genesis a toujours eu
une vision assez conceptuelle et
progressiste du rock'n'roll
c'est ce qu'on peut dire qu'à l'époque
on essaie de mélanger différentes
influences différents styles music voilà
en 1971 la formation définitive est en
place avec Phil Collins
vous avez toujours rêvé d'être un grand
batteur non c'est pas un grand regret
pour vous
en tout cas j'avais pas le même talent
que Phil Collins donc pour moi vous
n'aviez des boîtes à rythme ce qui nous
a permis de d'exprimer un peu tout ça de
manière artificielle ce qui m'a bien plu
lequel des deux est le plus riche
aujourd'hui
on fait certainement bien plus riche que
moi
sans aucun doute alors ce qui nous a
beaucoup surpris à l'époque quand on a
vu arriver Genesis c'est votre idée
d'utiliser les maquillages les masques
les costumes vous par exemple vous
faisiez des concerts où vous aviez une
tête de renard ou alors vous arriviez
avec des ailes de chauve-souris alors
maintenant ça a l'air de rien mais c'est
vrai qu'au début des années 70 c'était
très très surprenant
de jouer avec cette cette façon de
choquer le public de surprendre en tout
cas et puis en même temps il y avait
beaucoup de guitares acoustiques qui
étaient tout le temps déréglées qui
n'est désaccordé plutôt et c'était la
responsabilité du chanteur de distraire
le public en quelque sorte de le
divertir donc je commençais à raconter
des histoires puis illustrer ces
histoires et puis ensuite les jouets sur
scène je crois qu'on peut dire que
Genesis a introduit la théâtralité dans
l'Europe quelque chose qui n'existait
pas avant alors évidemment il y a eu un
énorme succès avec Céline ingland by the
pound et l'apogée est atteinte pour
Genesis avec de l'ambly il a alors ça
c'est incroyable au moment où le groupe
est à son apogée vous quittez le groupe
un petit peu assez d'aller dans le sens
du groupe c'est-à-dire que tout avait
été pré-organisé en quelque sorte des
années avant je savais très bien où
j'allais être à tel endroit tel moment
ciao tout était prêt programmé puis
ensuite avec la naissance de mon premier
enfant il y a eu un problème
a eu un problème à l'accouchement et là
d'un seul coup vous avez pris conscience
où vous êtes dit finalement
et puis parce que j'étais parents
j'étais papa bien avant les autres
membres du groupe les autres n'avaient
pas beaucoup de sympathie pour moi après
ça votre époque solo commence vous
commencez par par découvrir on peut dire
la world music un soir en zappant sur un
poste de radio en eau de moyenne
que je pourrais utiliser moi-même dans
ma propre dans ma propre musique mais
j'aimais beaucoup les radios à Hong
Kourt surtout j'écoutais de la musique
africaine sur une petite station
néerlandaise je me rappelle les rythmes
africains les voix tout cela semblait
présenter une autre image de la musique
quelque chose de tout à fait passionnant
alors ensuite vous lancez dans les
actions humanitaires amnistie witness
vous êtes une espèce de de citoyen du
monde
d'ailleurs vous avez une idée vous avez
une idée pour diriger le monde ça serait
un comité des sages vous pensez que en
fait il faudrait renforcer l'ONU et qui
a un comité des sages élus qui dirige le
monde
d'utiliser les personnes qui ont une
certaine expérience du monde de la ville
le problème souvent dans la classe
politique c'est que les hommes
politiques ne pensent qu'à la prochaine
échéance électorale donc il est assez
difficile de faire intervenir des
politiques qui auront une incidence sur
le long terme
alors si par exemple on pense la culture
des Indiens d'Amérique il examinait leur
politique sur des périodes de 7 de
plusieurs générations c'était les tribus
des anciens qui prévoyaient les
politiques des générations à venir alors
il y a encore sur ce qu'il y a des
personnes qui ont une autorité morale
mais qui n'ont pas de poids politique et
il semble dommage de ne pas se servir de
ce talent de manière plus constructive
surtout maintenant que la technologie
est là pour le faire
bien alors vous êtes intéressé à peu
près à tout multimédia et au Bonobo
Laurent au Bonobo tu sais que les
bonobos sont notre plus proche cousin
99% de comment avec l'homme
contrairement chimpanzé qui n'en a que
98 % voilà il ne pense qu'à baiser
Gabriel dit que finalement on a beaucoup
d'arrogans parce que si on arrivait sur
une planète et qu'on trouve des êtres
avec 99% de gènes identiques au nôtres
en les respecterait alors que là nous on
se prend pour des génies et les bonobos
on les prend pour des pour des primates
ignorants
on a commencé à jouer au piano ensemble
et puis il y avait effectivement une
intelligence musicale en présence là
c'était quelque chose de vraiment
passionnant
alors maintenant ce que nous essayons de
faire
je crois qu'il y a une douzaine de
primates qui comprennent notre langue on
essaie de les de les connecter par
internet et leur donner les moyens de
communiquer entre eux d'abord
un perroquet africain qui a beaucoup de
talent vous intéressez vraiment à tout
vous êtes intéressé à un moment à
Rosanna Arquette aussi
c'est vrai
quand même Rosanna vous êtes toujours
avec des musiciens et comment ça se fait
et elle m'a répondu c'est sans doute
parce que j'aime leurs instruments
j'imagine que vous avez un instrument de
qualité vous êtes aussi intéressé à
chenet de Connor
vous avez déclaré en parlant d'elle
c'est une montagne russe émotionnelle ça
veut dire quoi ça
il y avait des hauts et des bas et des
soubresauts des rebondissements très
rapides ah des rebondissements très
rapides
bien Peter vous êtes une vraie Rockstar
alors on va voir Peter Gabriel si 30 ans
après Genesis vous êtes encore une vraie
Rockstar et on va faire une interview
Rockstar
Gabriel est-ce que vous avez saccagé la
chambre du palace dans lequel vous êtes
descendu à Paris
il fallait il fallait ne pas toucher au
savonnettes c'était peut-être la chose
la plus dangereuse qu'on est jamais
faite est-ce que vous boxer
régulièrement des paparazzis
pas souvent par régulièrement est-ce que
des filles affirment régulièrement que
les enfants qu'elles ont sont de vous
toujours c'est très Rockstar ça
[Rires]
avec les gorilles qui sont peut-être un
peu jaloux
est-ce que vous avez des ennuis
judiciaires à cause de la drogue
pas souvent non
histoire bien tragique est-ce que vous
avez acheté un restaurant une boîte de
nuit qui vous a ruiné
peut-être un petit hôtel par contre et
ça vous a coûté du blé
est-ce que vous êtes tellement Rockstar
que plus personne n'ose vous contredire
quand vous dites une connerie
est-ce que vous choisissez dans le
public tous les soirs une fille qu'on
vous ramène après dans votre chambre
pourquoi une seule
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Gabriel merci d'avoir été avec nous je
sais que votre avion vous attend sur le
tarmac et que vous décollez pour
l'Angleterre mon vélo aussi votre vélo
aussi merci Peter
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu